from the Democrat to the Republican
Party in 1964 this is about 45 minutes
I want to talk to you today about my
book Strom Thurmond's America and I want
to begin by telling you a story of my
Strom Thurmond story now when you go and
you do research in South Carolina and
you go into archives and people ask you
what you're interested in writing about
and you tell them Strom Thurmond then
they say oh let me tell you my story
about Strom Thurmond here you can't
throw a stone in South Carolina without
hitting somebody who's got a great story
you know about Strom Thurmond the time
you did something for him or the time
that they saw him do something crazy or
that kind of thing so my story about
Strom Thurmond begins in its late July
1992 and I'm on a flight from Washington
DC to Charlotte North Carolina and I had
been an intern that summer up on Capitol
Hill and one of my regrets of the summer
was that I had never seen Strom Thurmond
because all my fellow interns said well
you got to see Strom Thurmond he has
such an unusual appearance about him I
didn't know what they meant really about
that but I had my suspicions so I'm on
the flight and I look ahead in front of
me and I see a man who's got these kind
of orange colored hair practically you
know so brightly color and these kind of
generations this first generation kind
of hair plugs and I think I'm in shows
you kind of how slow I am that I think
to myself that must be what Strom
Thurmond's heads heads looks like and of
course it wasn't the Strom Thurmond I
knew that when people were reaching over
and trying you know trying to shake his
hand and not coming well I wanted to
shake his hand too because I've been in
DC that summer for the first time and
I'd met all of these politicians that
seen on TV and it'd been a great thrill
and I was about to go home and speak to
my dad's Rotary Club and I wanted to
tell him you know all about the famous
people that I'd met up in Washington DC
and so I was gonna try to shake his hand
when I got off the plane but as I got
off the plane there were people already
lined up to shake his hand and and I
didn't get in line and I I didn't you
know I think I wasn't a constituent I'm
not a South Carolinian I don't have
anything really to say to him
really and I also to be honest was a
little self-conscious it was a busy
airport there were a lot of different
kinds of people in there and I was kind
of self-conscious about standing in line
waiting to greet a man who's best known
for his old you know segregationist her
ranks so I thought it was a you know
good enough just to kind of say that I
had seen him and and keep on walking but
I get down the conquer I'm conflicted
though I'm conflicted and I walk down
the concourse about a hundred yards and
I look back and here everybody had
dispersed they'd shake at his hand and
here's this 89 year old man at the time
he's got a suitcase he's got a briefcase
in one hand and a travel bag in the
other and a in a package under one arm
and he's just shuffling down this busy
crowded airport and without thinking I
go back and I introduced myself and I
said senator Thurmond my name is Joe
Crispino I don't Calpol he'll this
summer I'd be happy to help you get to
your next flight and he said well you
sure you got enough time I don't want to
delay you you know in your own travels
and I said no so I've got plenty time
I'd be happy to do it and so I picked up
his bags and we walked together for
about ten minutes and you know and I was
just trying to make conversation with
Strom Thurmond and so I told him about
all the people I'd met that summer and
and he said nice things about the
various colleagues that I met and that
kind of thing I told him that was on my
way to now had a girlfriend from
Florence South Carolina and I said some
silly comment about South Carolina girls
I guess because you know seeing the kind
of small talk one made with Strom
Thurmond and I got him to his flight and
I shook his hand again and that was it
but I thought about that story a lot as
I've written this book because that
story really is a metaphor for the
difficulty I had in writing about this
there or the challenge that I faced in
writing about this very controversial
figure you know there's no easy or
straightforward way to write about a
figure as controversial as Strom
Thurmond and sometimes as I've been
reading this book I've wondered if some
of this stuff in this book is not
another effort on my part to kind of
carry Strom Thurmond's bags you know
carry his baggage and goodness knows
he's got baggage that needs carrying you
know
but the other challenge that had really
the the real challenge I had in this
book was to kind of fight the urge to
not kind of not to kind of you know
simply walk away and not meet the man
face-to-face
you know and present him as a kind of
three-dimensional character some you
know real living breathing human being
so that's the challenge I faced and what
what I wanted to do really is to to
write a book about write a history of
Strom Thurmond's America in a way that
would in a critical but dispassionate
way in a way that would shed light on
some of the issues that have shaped you
know each of our own Americas today and
I hope that in doing so you can add a
sense of a measure of reason and this
passion to these issues that embroil our
politics today and that divided us so so
that was the goal that's the mission as
it were but but uh but what are those
big issues what are the issues that that
a history of Strom Thurmond's America
speaks to we remember a lot of us
remember who Strom Thurmond was Strom
Thurmond was the 1948 Dixiecrat
presidential candidate Strom Thurmond
was one of the lead authors of the 1956
southern manifesto which is the the
protest of the Supreme Court's decision
in the Brown versus Board of Education
decision 1954 Shawn Thurmond is the
record holder to this day of the longest
one-man filibuster it's in the Guinness
Book of World Records 24 hours and 18
minutes he spoke against the 1957 civil
rights bill we remember Strom Thurmond
today is one of the last of the Jim Crow
demagogues and he was he was that he was
one of the last of the Jim Crow
demagogues but what we forget about
Thurmond is that he was also one of the
first of the Sunbelt conservatives now
what do I mean by that
what's the Sunbelt conservative now the
Sun Belt it's one of the big stories
it's one of the major stories in the
history of 20th century American
politics and that is the
of jobs of industries of resources and
population from the states of the
Northeast in the Midwest to the south
and the southwest in the post-world War
two period you know southern states were
recruiting industries right they were
passing right-to-work laws they were
receiving lots of funding from the
federal government to build military
installations at a time when the United
States was involved in a cold war
against the Soviet Union so states like
Mississippi but states like Georgia and
Texas in Florida and Southern California
in Arizona and North Carolina are all
being transformed in the post-world War
two period by this by this historic
shift in population and political
influence let me just think about it
this really this period from 1964 to
2008 could be think could be thought of
it's kind of the period of the Sun Belt
dominance in American presidential
history if you think about every
president elected from 1964 to 2008
comes from a state of the Sunbelt Lyndon
Johnson from Texas Richard Nixon from
California Gerald Ford was never elected
he was not even elected vice president
so he doesn't count he was from Michigan
Jimmy Carter from Georgia Ronald Reagan
from California the first George Bush
from Texas via Connecticut you know Bill
Clinton from Arkansas and in a second
Bush from from Texas so 2008 is in some
ways a watershed election right it ends
this 40-year period of Sun Belt
dominance and there were issues that
were critical in the politics that
developed that came out of the Sun Belt
they tended to have a conservative cast
to them they tended to be oriented
around issues of strong national defense
of an opposition to unions and a defense
of free enterprise politics and also
it's in the Sun Belt in the south and
the Southwest that we see the rise of
what we by the 1970s will be coming to
talk about as the religious right the
rise of evangelical and fundamentalist
voters involved in the political process
in new and important ways
so Thurmond was at the forefront of all
of those issues in his own politics you
know national defense he was a staunch
anti-communist and played an important
role in right-wing anti-communist
populist politics
in the late 50s and early 1960s it's one
of the things that led him to to switch
parties in 1964 he was a key figure in
opposing labor unions and he did so
alongside people like Barry Goldwater
starting in the late 1950s even though
early in his career he'd been a staunch
advocate of unions in South Carolina
back in the 30s and 40s when the union
vote was an important vote in South
Carolina but he switches in the 50s and
60s and by the 1970s becomes a die-hard
supporter of business against labor and
then he also is an important role in
conservative evangelical politics you
know he joins the board of Bob Jones
University in 1950 he does it to win
votes in the upcountry of South Carolina
Bob Jones had just moved to some country
of South Korea just moved his university
and Thurman needed votes in the
upcountry of South Carolina he had lost
the 1950 race for the Senate to öland
Johnson largely on the strength of votes
that he didn't win in the upcountry and
that began a long a long process a long
relationship of a Thurman but with with
conservative fundamentalist and
evangelical folks who were looking to
get involved in the political process
and the sway the political process so we
need to understand Thurman's racial
politics in the midst of these other
conservative causes these conservative
issues that he was very involvement and
to see how they intersect with one
another and I think doing so gives us a
history of what Strom Thurmond's America
looks like and it helps us rethink not
only what was going on in the south but
what was going on in in in the national
conservative political realm as well
rethinking Strom Thurmond helps us
rethink the history of modern
conservatism a history I think that too
often Thurman is left out of because we
only remember is this kind of cartoonish
racist figure from the deep south let me
read you an excerpt from the
introduction and it speaks to this point
one reason we forget about Strom
Thurmond is because he was so doggone
old right
Thurman Thurman predated the founding
generation of what is commonly
understood as the modern conservative
movement he was a closer friend to
William F Buckley senior then WM F
Buckley Jr the founding editor of
National Review and one of the central
figures of modern conservatism Buckley
our senior who restored an antebellum
estate in Camden South Carolina and
became a friend and regular
correspondent with the then governor
Thurmond would have had no problem
identifying as a Strom Thurmond American
I don't know of any other man in public
life whose views I entirely approve off
he wrote to Thurmond in 1956 his son had
just started a new magazine and Buckley
sent Thurman a year subscription
he told Thurmond that his son was a very
fine public speaker and very sound
adding he is for segregation and backs
it in every issue one of the most
notorious editorials Buckley Jr
published in national reviews early
years came during a signature battle in
Thurman's career the fight against the
1957 civil rights bill why the South
must prevail appeared four days before
Thurman's historic filibuster this and
I'm quoting now from that editorial 57
in the National Review the central
question that emerges is whether the
white community in the south is entitled
to take such measures as they're
necessary to prevail politically and
culturally in areas in which it does not
predominate numerically the sobering
answer is yes the white community is so
entitled because for the time being it
is the advanced race Buckley Jr and
Thurmond would seem to occupy separate
polls in conservative politics their
accents alone mark their different
backgrounds and experiences it is easy
to forget that Buckley was once a
fledgling writer and publisher trying to
insinuate himself into a world of
politics and letters the son of a
nouveau riche oil baron and that
Thurmond was a priceless contact for
father and son both later after the sea
change inaugurated by the civil rights
movement Thurmond would not be the only
conservative leader with a
segregationist record in need of
scrubbing
the mid 20th century American right was
a smaller more interconnected world than
we often remember now
I think Strom Thurmond's life is
interesting for the light that it sheds
on Southern and that when we see it
properly for the light it sheds on
southern and national politics in the
second half of the 20th century but
Strom Thurmond's life is also
interesting simply as a life I mean the
man lived to be a hundred years old it
was full of twists and turns it was full
of psychological complexity and
unintended consequences and it was full
of secrets too right we know the secret
of his having fathered an
african-american daughter right that we
learned about after his death now I want
to talk a little bit too about the
motivations of Thurmond what drove him
and a lot of that comes back to his
childhood but the most important figure
in Thurman's life was his father his
father had an interesting career his
father was an up-and-coming young
politician kind of in the political
machine of pitchfork Ben Tillman Ben
Tillman was the biggest man in South
Carolina politics in the turn of the
century one of the ends also an infamous
kind of demagogue of the Jim Crow cell
right and he was the biggest man in
South Carolina and Thurman's father was
kind of a lieutenant in his operation
Thurman's father had been elected a kind
of a county prosecuting attorney and he
was a successful career here as a
successful raid was on the rise when he
got into a dispute one afternoon with a
man actually the man picked the fight
with Thurmond saying that he had he was
complaining about a position that his
father had not been appointed to man was
drunk
and he was very he cursed Thurmond and
all that kind of stuff they got into a
row Thurmond walked back to his law
office the man came back around
Thurmond ended up shooting the man and
he was acquitted if for self-defense but
if you're trying to build a political
career is that the county's biggest law
enforcement official it doesn't help if
you've murdered if you've been
top Ameri right that's not that's not
good and in fact Thurman would run for
the House of Representatives a couple
years later and he ended up finishing a
distant third he wouldn't ever run for
electoral office again but he ended up
being an important kind of
behind-the-scenes guy I got important
behind-the-scenes figure in in South
Carolina politics and he would he would
support important candidates and he was
kind of about he would kind of managed
things behind the scenes and one of the
one of the campaign's that he managed
was a campaign that was very influential
in the in the life of young Strom
Thurmond it was the 1912 gubernatorial
election between ira jones who was a
former Speaker of the House in South
Carolina that was the candidate that
Strom Thurmond father will Thurmond
supported IRA Jones versus coal bleeds
Coleman bleeds was another important
figure out of South Carolina politics a
very influential figure in Thurmond
would always tell the story Strom
Thurmond would about how he when people
asked him how'd you get involved in
politics when did you know you wanted to
be a politician he said I remember when
I was nine went out back when I was a
boy I saw that race between IRA Jones
and coal bleeds and I saw how Cole Blees
cut you know I saw what he did to IRA
Jones on the stump and I always vowed
that I would learn how to speak on the
stump and I'd be able to defend myself
and there's a certain irony to that
stories because Thurmond was never known
for his skills on the stump as a speaker
but that's the way he remembered it
right that's the way he always told that
story and he told it over and over when
reporters would ask him that question
it's a formative story and I think that
some of the Thurman's other biographers
have kind of missed what's important and
what's interesting about that story
Strom Thurmond recalled the debate
between Blees and Jones as his first
lesson in political self-defense and the
importance of being skilled in the
verbal warfare of the stump yet Jones's
humiliation was always matched in
Thurman's memory by Belize's mastery and
the power it gave them with the masses
in 1912 at age nine Thurmond encountered
up close at an impressionable age the
power of the demagogue
and experience both fearsome and
alluring Thurmond himself drew on this
background 36 years later when as a
presidential candidate he stoked the
racist resentments of states rights
Democrats it was in Birmingham in July
1948 that Thurmond offered his own form
of Blees ISM swearing that there are not
enough troops in the army to force
southerners to abandon segregation it
was Lee's ISM that he drew upon during
the 24 hours and 18 minutes he spent
denouncing the civil rights bill of 1957
as well as in other firebrand orations
he gave in the massive resistance era
such as a 1958 speech declaring quote
total and unremitting war on the Supreme
Court's unconstitutional usurpations and
unlawful irrigations of power yet
Thurmond also remembered the disdain of
his father and other towns folk for
blaze how believes mocked the attitudes
and opinions of the thinking people it
was one reason perhaps why later in his
career Thurmond would embrace a kind of
magical thinking about his own
adventures in demagoguery denying them
outright or attempting to rationalize
them into something other than mere
Blees ISM for the rest of his career the
polls between which Strom Thurmond's
political ambitions would swing were
established in that 1912 race
the intelligent honorable Jones was also
hamstrung and toothless pleas despicable
as he was the Thurman's father and his
circle of respectable leaders was
stylish clever in formidable it would
seem that the fair-minded in the
principled became vaguely commingled in
Thurman's mind with political weakness
and perhaps too with his father's failed
ambitions while what others decried as
illicit and demagogue ik Thurmond knew
to be something else as well a key to
men's fears and passions a path to the
influence and renown that his father
always longed for but never achieved
now there's one more thing I want to say
about Strom Thurmond early years and it
revolves around a one of the great
things I found I was doing research for
this book I found it through a gentleman
from from Edgefield South Carolina
Thurman's home men and mr. beddows
Ransford who was himself an amateur
historian a lawyer there in Edgefield a
very talented historian and a close
friend of the of the Thurman's who
pointed me to it to a history a
biography of a man named Francis Butler
Simpkins now Francis Butler Simpkins was
in his own day a very well-known
historian of the South in France in fact
Francis Butler Simpkins kind of magnum
opus is a biography of pitchfork Ben
Tillman you know from his own hometown
so Simpkins grew up in this small town
in South Carolina was always kind of
fascinated with his own hometown and at
some point he sat down to write this
kind of gossipy thinly fictionalized
account of his hometown called edge
field called Lich Wood it was called in
his text this thing was never published
it's it's it's now preserved only in the
archives at Longwood University in
Virginia where Simpkins taught for his
old life but it offers a really unique
perspective on straw on-edge field in
the air in which Strom Thurmond was
growing up in an era in which will
Thurmond was the biggest most
influential figure in Edgefield
political life there in the early
nineteen teens and 20s so let me just
read you a little bit of this and then
I'm going to stop talking
so sometime in the late 1940s or early
1950s Frances Butler simpkin sat down to
write a gossipy thinly fictionalized
memoir about growing up in Edgefield or
lynchwood
as it appears in his text it was never
published and it's preserved today only
in his personal papers in longwood the
untitled manuscript is fascinating for
the light it sheds on his one-time
neighbor Simpkins actually grew up on
the road in the house right across from
where Strom Thurmond grew up Simpkins
was five years older this drama Thurman
and he wrote about two characters was
suited with the name Hogg Stoops and his
son stoned and these quote-unquote
fictional characters follow so exactly
the real-life accomplishments of will
and strom thurmond as to make the
pseudonym superfluous at one point
Simpkins even slips and refers to hog
Stoops as will Stoops despite some minor
errors in fact the manuscript provides
an intimate perspective on will and
Strom Thurmond and on Edgefield now
sentences treatment of hog Stoops is
relatively generous describing hog is
cold-blooded in his law practice learned
in the technicalities of the law without
the remotest interest in justice or
impolite culture Simpkins also
pronounced in deserving of the honorary
degree awarded him by the University of
South Carolina hog was Richards man of
moderation and charity who quote refused
to speak unkindly of anyone the town's
most popular citizen for forty years yet
the distinctive quality that emerges
from Simpkins portrait of hog Stoops was
that of a remarkably adroit fixer Stoops
quote ruled lynchwood County through
machinations so secret that one for
decades could live under his authority
without being aware of its existence it
was the quality that it led believes to
deride him as a pussyfoot that's the
other thing I didn't tell you about that
1912 election is that Cole Blees didn't
just attack ira jones on the stump
he actually attacked Strom Thurmond's
father in front of the young Strom
Thurmond called him pussyfoot bill for
the way that he was he went around
behind people's backs and didn't confer
his political enemies man to man you
know that kind of thing
Simpkins wrote of a man whose candidacy
for prosecuting attorney was bloodlessly
cut short by Stoops as well as of a
schoolmaster whose dismissal Stoops
quietly engineered despite visiting the
man before he left town to tell him how
grieved he was to see him go stone
Stoops however was of a slightly
different breed while possessing his
father's sobriety pleasing manners
industry and willingness to scheme to
accomplish personal ambition he was only
half students the other was stoned and
it was from his mother's side of the
family that he was said to have
inherited a penchant for acts of wild
folly he had an uncle in his mother's
side who was quote possessed of an
energy so maniacal that he dissipated a
fortune in numerous foolish enterprises
Stone lacked hogs good sense and
deceptiveness Simpkins wrote what his
father achieved by indirection stone
pursued openly and in the process
attracted enemies characteristics of hog
and stone Stoops and Simpkins as memoir
provide context for a defining event in
the lives of will and strom thurmond in
the mid 1920s when Strom was living at
home in Edgefield and teaching at the
local high school a situation developed
inside wools household owing to one of
strahm's
acts of wild folly among the servants
employed at Thurman's large home on Penn
Street was a 16-year old
african-american girl named Carrie
Butler in October 1925 Butler gave birth
to a daughter whom she named SMA six
months later
Butler's sister took SEMA with her to
Pennsylvania where she was moving with
her husband she passed the child to
another sister Mary Washington who
raised SMA as her own not until she was
13 years old that Essie Mae learned the
identity of her actual mother three
years later she met her father Strom
Thurmond in his law office just off the
town square in Edgefield se May's birth
in October coincided with an abrupt
occupational change for Thurman he had
been a schoolteacher in Edgefield and he
leaved the the pay
Augusta announces on the very day that
SEMA is born announces that all as he's
quit his job in the middle of the school
year it has taken a job with a
real-estate firm he's going to be sent
to he's going to be assigned in in
Richmond Virginia and he stays in that
job as a real estate agent in Virginia
until several months after Essie Mae as
an infant had been moved to Pennsylvania
but then he comes back to edge field
County and starts his career again
teaching high school Thurman departed
from Edgefield the same month of se
May's birth and returned a few months
after the child had been moved to
Pennsylvania we do not know whether will
Thurman played any role in strahm's
temporary career change or in SE mays
being sent to pennsylvania and it's hard
to imagine however that a man so careful
with appearances so mindful of his
reputation in Edgefield and throughout
South Carolina and so hopeful about his
son's ambitions would not have had some
hand in making sure that the young man's
indiscretions did not imperil his future
prospects will Thurmond knew by hard
experience how a youthful mistake could
forever alter a political career perhaps
he had used legal and financial contacts
to help get strong out of town for a
while
perhaps he handed over money to ensure
the baby was transported out of the
state if that had been his desire a
quiet conversation with some of Kerry
Butler's relatives was all that would
have been required later the Thurman's
would regularly pass money to Essie
Mae's caregivers and when she came of
age to Essie Mae herself if Frances
Butler Simpkins is to be believed there
may have been a difference between
father and son a sense of judgment or
discretion that did not make it from one
generation to the next
yet there remains an awesome fact that
testifies to the son's abilities as a
fixer the details of his act of
miscegenation a secret that likely would
have ended his career had it been
revealed at practically any point in his
nearly 3/4 century of public service
he took with him to his grave now that's
that's that's a story about how that
secret began and begin I believe really
with will Thurman and with will
Thurman's ambitions for his father
it's a markable that how that secret
persisted for so long course by the
1990s it became the worst kept secret in
South Carolina and everybody suspected
it after some newspaper reporters
tracked down
SEMA Washington Williams living in Los
Angeles but there were other hints of it
along the way like in one of the great
documents I've found was for 1957 when
Thurmond gave his filibuster you know
for 24 hours and 18 minutes there was an
item published in the african-american
newspaper the Chicago Defender and the
bulk of the item was puzzling over how
it was that Thurmond was able to speak
for 24 hours and 18 minutes with only
one bathroom break right I mean you got
to keep your voice you know lubricated
right you got to keep drinking water
now the story all that that Thurmond
told to the press was that he had gone
down to the Senate steam room and had
intentionally dehydrated himself so that
when he drank water his body would
absorb it like a sponge now ask the
urologist friend of mine about the you
know the viability of that and he was
pretty dubious but that's the story
that's the story that's always been told
but what was interesting about that
piece in the african-american newspaper
in the Chicago Defender they said that
the rumor around the Capitol Hill was
that Thurmond had been outfitted with a
device designed for long motor trips
some kind of cat that there like the
visor what's interesting about that is
there was a memoir published a couple
years ago by an african-american man
from South Carolina a longtime worker on
Capitol Hill who says that he was there
when the when Thurmond was outfitted for
this bag that ran down his leg but
there's been no other evidence for the
or that kind of thing so it's one of the
no it's a one of those neurological
mysteries
about about strong sermons career but at
the end of that item that was largely
about the mystery of the filibuster was
this oblique statement said something
like there are you know there are rumors
or there's talk of that Thurmond is not
as opposed to black people as it might
seem you know now you could take that to
say there were there had been rumors
published in 1948 when he's a Dixiecrat
presidential candidate that he had black
cousins in Edgefield now it could be
referring to that but we also know that
SEMA was already enrolled in in school
in South Carolina at that time and that
there had already been rumors in the
black community ever since then that she
was the governor's daughter and it comes
up again and there's a remarkable thing
of course it happens after Thurmond
passes away when SEMA Washington
Williams holes of public news conference
in South Col and says Strom Thurmond was
my father
and they changed the Strom Thurmond
monument in South Carolina it was a
black legislature in the state assembly
who said we've got the name of his other
four children on that monument and so we
should put SEMA Washington Williams name
too and they did and there was a
resolution that was passed and they
changed the monument you know that old
that old saying if it's written in stone
you know it's written in stone you can't
change it that's not true change stone
all the time they have to because they
get the dates wrong about when people
die or when they're born or their names
are spelled wrong and I talked to the
guy who owns the company that changed
the Strom Thurmond memorial there in
Columbia and what you do is you take
granite dust you pound that granite
until it's a fine powder and then you
mix it with Krazy Glue seriously you can
mix it with just plain old Krazy Glue
which when it hardens is actually harder
than the stone itself and they take that
mixture and they pound it in to where
the other is the letters had been carved
and actually pounded into it so it's
above the surface of the stone and then
they have to sand it smooth and then
they carve back over the filled in area
so they had to replace that was the
trick they could add SD maze name on the
bottom there was space there but they
said father
for children and they had to change the
four to a five so when they card backed
over that filled an area if you don't
get that granite powder really really
fine
it's got to be finer than like baby
powder because if you don't when you
carve back over it's prone to chipping
if you look closely that five the eye
and that fives got a chip on it on the
upper right side and the V the left side
of the V is all squiggly had been
chipped there too and the sanding had
that kind of opened up that stone the
other ores that are in the stone the
sanding opened up those other ores
to air and they've oxidized it's kind of
got a rust color all around the word v
and it's the whole thing has been you
know you can change stone but you can't
change it very easily and and and you
can see what is in effect a kind of scar
on that monument the stone has been
scarred by the work that's been done to
change that for into a five and in the
epilogue you kind of reflect on the
meaning of that scar different ways that
different people could read the
significance of the scarred stone and
and and in reading that stone in that
monument think about the legacy of strom
thurmond on our politics today in the
south and in the nation if you want to
know more about how you can read that
stone I encourage you to buy this book
and read it for yourself and you might
learn something I'll and I'll even sign
the book today it's a painless process I
promise it's been a pleasure to be here
and thank you all for listening coming
out
and if the I think most of you probably
if you have questions you've probably
asked them to me before in another
context but if there are any questions
I'd be happy to field them I have a
question I'm David McNamara we're so
very proud to know you and I'm sure that
Bob is smiling
my question is about Trent law and his
time in back when he got in trouble by
crazy engine and saying that me that he
uses his mentor I think at 40 know me he
said that the state that that he was
proud to his state had voted for turn
him back in 48 and if other states had
followed the country wouldn't had all
the problems yeah did you address that
yeah I mentioned it in real time I mean
it happened first in 1980 he said that
1980 when he was introducing Thurman
here in Jackson Thurman was the main
speaker at a rally for Ronald Reagan a
few days before the 1980 presidential
election and and for me it was
interesting it's interesting for a lot
to say that in 1980 because lot is is
really in some ways a kind of figurative
child is drawn through in the last
chapter the book is called all strahm's
children and it's where I deal with the
revelations about SEMA Washington
Williams but I also try to put that in a
broader historical context and say that
that these are Strom Thurmond literal
children before he had is Nancy Thurmond
and then SEMA Washington Williams but
they're also figuratively near there are
a generation of southerners have kind of
who switched you've done this big switch
right but Democrats voted for it so so
that's what I talked about in the last
in the last chapter so yeah so I talked
about that incident just as the kind of
part of the kind of Thurman's reaction
and other southerners reaction to Reagan
in 1980 and then that that party in
which Lott says that again in 2002 this
was in December of 2002 that was really
kind of a it was Thurman's 100th
birthday party but it was also Scott and
some ones that kind of going-away party
because he would his last year was in
the Senate was his term was up in
January 2003 he goes back to Edgehill
and he only lives for six
and and at that point it's an
interesting moment because that
controversy kind of raises for the whole
of you know the kind of modern
conservative movement who is Strom
Thurmond and what role has he played
that's also who was Trent Lott right and
what role is he played in this politics
and in what's interesting about that is
how other Republicans and other
conservatives are responding to that
issue you know in responding to that
controversy and so that's part of the
analysis too because that that's they're
they're interpreting Thurman and of
course what a lot of national
conservative leaders are doing they're
trying to keep Thurman as the kind of
crazy ol uncle up and of the
conservative revolution you know the guy
who's not really important to this you
know conservative movement that's been
going on in the last fifty years or so
and what part of my book is arguing is
that Thurmond was there all along at key
moments and was a key figure and that
people did take him seriously it's not
just like Republican strategists thought
Thurmond was a kook you know they didn't
think he was a kook you know Goldwater
didn't think it was a kook when he was
trying to get Thurman to switch parties
and endorse him in 1964 Richard Nixon
certainly didn't think it was a kook but
Thurmond helped him you know carry key
states of the south when George Wallace
was running in 1968 you know so that was
that's an important you know so that's
that's that controversy raised those
broader issues really about Thurman's
role in modern conservative history and
it's one of the things that sparked me
you know the idea for me to write the
book in the first place
do you make much mention of pickle be
right when you write about the 48
reservation campaign uh you know
fielding write-in strom thurmond work
before they were on the same ticket
there were something of rivals right in
fact it's a fascinating story that early
on that the the whole Dixie crack thing
Burt is in reaction to an address that
that Truman gave a set of proposals that
Truman gave in early forty-eight and all
the southern governors meet in North
Florida
outside of Tallahassee at a governor's
conference and that's where the whole
thing starts and fielding right was that
was the hardest line one there he said
we got to leave the Democratic Party we
got to leave it now and Thurmond and
it's worked out by his close advisers
says no they said what we need is a
forty day a cooling-off period where we
kind of figure out what we're gonna do
in that kind of thing and Thurmond
offered a resolution for a cooling-off
period and that's what we got adopted
but then as he was asking people what
they should do he had realized that not
too many people were interested in
cooling off they wanted to stay fired up
and Thurmond wound and Thurman then kind
of doubled down and said I need to keep
involved in this and the written the
reason that many people in South
Carolina recognize this at the time is
that Thurmond was looking ahead to 1950
his good natori atern would be up in
1950 he couldn't succeed himself in
South Carolina politics and he wanted to
run for the Senate is the next thing on
his next rung on the ladder and to do
that he had to get to the right of Olin
Johnson who was an establishment new
dealer and so in some ways it's ironic
Thurmond runs for president so he can
run for the Senate in some ways you know
he runs for the presidency in 48 to
establish you know establish himself
among the states rights crowd in South
Carolina and across the region make a
name for himself there because
ironically enough he had been thought of
up to that point something of liberal in
South Carolina for a number of different
reasons because of his labor politics
but also because
of he had called FBI in to investigate a
lynching that had happened in in South
Carolina 1947 and that was not a popular
thing to do
to call in the FBI to investigate a
lynching but but that's all in the book
there's a fascinating moment in his
career because that's really when a lot
of things are really moving around both
in his career and in southern politics
yes well Haley Barbour certainly played
a huge role in modern Republican
politics its enormous Lee a talented guy
who's you know started off in in
Mississippi politics and rose to great
prominence Lynette Rodina Party Chairman
in 96 but there been a lot a lot you
know he's been a he was an important
figure in kind of important southerner
in in building the modern GOP but you
know there have been important South
Carolinians - Lee Atwater
I mean Atwater is the guy who comes out
of Herman's political shop you know that
really has a huge influence on GOP
politics in the 1980s you know runs
George Bush's campaign in 1988 so I
don't talk about Barbour simply because
this is really about it's about Thurmond
story and his influence and and I mean
I'm sure haley barbour Strom Thurmond
met many times but they were you know
they were coming out different states
and they weren't well but but Atwater
you know with big Barbara's age you know
they were the same generation and
Thurmond had an important I mean you
know Thurmond was around a long time
forty-eight years in the Senate so but
it's more about you know the fact that
Barbara's from Mississippi and rather
than South Carolina that he wouldn't
have been a part of this book
any other questions well thank y'all
again oh yeah yes you criticize man in
the Wall Street Journal oh I'm so glad
you brought this up I did not ask him to
ask this question right they've made me
lady Lee Edwards Leah that's right who
is also a bad as you are and he's a
story he's written several histories of
the conservative movement he himself has
been a member of the conservative move
an important person in that no it's not
jealousy it's not jacking tell you that
but one of the things that did
disappoint me about mr. Edwards being
asked to write that review is that one
of the things he he takes issue with is
that Colin Thurman's ghostwriter for the
only book Thurman wrote in 1968 well it
was Thurman staffers former staffers of
Thurman who had characterized his work
on the book as being ghost writing I
talked to them and after talking to them
I emailed mr. Edwards and I asked him if
I could interview him about his
relationship Strom Thurmond what work he
did and that kind of thing and mr.
Edwards says been 40 years ago you know
any interview would be a waste of your
time in mind so my only thing I conduces
that he was saving up his time to write
a criticism of the book once it came out
and he got a number of other things
wrong you tie he quoted Goldwater
speaking with Thurmond and talking about
the importance of equal rights in
Columbia South Carolina a few days
before the presidential campaign in 1964
what he doesn't say about that meeting
is that it began by everybody singing
Dixie that there was many Confederate
flags as American flags rate and that
the New York Times reported in that
meeting that a considerable section in
the speech was devoted to denouncing the
1964 Civil Rights Act you know and any
review that says that the only key
issues in Thurman's career were
constitutionalism and national security
I don't think can be taken as I mean I
don't think that passes the laughs test
of what we all know about strong
theremin his career so I was
disappointed that the Wall Street
Journal thought that this man who had a
close relationship with them had been
employed by Thurmond he admits that in
the review that they fought thought that
he was the best person to evaluate the
book for their readers I thought that
was disappointing you had no knowledge
that Edward that lead was going to be
they didn't tell you no no and he was
going to be the person that no other New
York Washington Post and Washington
Monthly do Google Strom Thurmond's
America you can find some and you should
Google what's next I don't know I'm not
sure I've just finished this one so I'm
still trying to figure it out now that
would be fascinating but I'm still
trying to know thank